(bassy hip hop)
- This is actually a very very important
Super Late Morning Show today.
We're having a Ja Rule release party.
He is not releasing an album
because he's in prison.
- So this is actually a release party
for him getting out of prison.
We got Big Homie here
on the ones and twos.
Know wham saying and you
know what, Big Homie,
give us three seconds of
some Ja Rule right now.
♫ Murda, holla holla
All right, the reason we're
playing three seconds is cause
legally we're only allowed
to play three seconds.
- We play more than three
seconds we get sued.
I'm not tryna go to jail for Ja Rule.
- Ladies and gentlement welcome
back to the Cipha Sounds
and Rosenberg show.
Now we got some special guests here.
- The Lucas brothers are here.
- [Lucases] What's up.
- Tell the people in New York City
this party you have planned.
- Okay, it's gonna be a
Ja Rule release party.
- Wait he has a record coming out?
- Nah, nah, he's getting
released from prison.
- He's getting out of jail.
- Because this is Hot 97,
if you come up to promote
you know we're gonna keep it 100% real.
No one's coming to this party.
- Why would you say--
- Do you not remember how
the Ja Rule story ended,
he was really hot, and
then he went to jail,
and then everyone forgot the
whole thing ever happened.
- Yeah but the heat was still on him.
I don't think the heat ever left.
- The heat never leaves Ja Rule.
Ja Rule leaves the heat.
(dubby music)
- So what's your favorite Ja Rule song?
- None.
- What's your favorite Ja Rule song?
- I don't have one.
- So what's your favorite Ja Rule song?
- I've never heard of him.
- You know what, there was
one that he did I think
with LL Cool J, where he
was talking about, um,
cannabis
and I think Ja Rule was on that.
- 5 4 3 2 1.
That was DMX.
- That's a classic.
- One of his great songs is Holla Holla,
you rememeber that one?
- No I don't know.
- Oh, where are you guys from?
- We are eh--
- We're from Spain.
- Spain.
So Ja Rule's international.
- Can you do your best Ja Rule impression?
- It's Ja Rule.
- Hi, I'm Ja Rule.
- It's muuurda!
- So we're having a Ja Rule
release from prison party.
- I didn't even know he was in prison.
♫ Baby girl put it on me
- Look, you can't have the
world's greatest Ja Rule party,
unless you have a party expert.
And we've got Andrew WK here for us.
(partiers clap)
- Happy to be here.
- What's your favorite Ja Rule song.
- I like Holla Holla.
Is it Holla Holla or just Holla?
- It's Holla comma Holla.
- Could you do a rap in his voice?
- His voice is special.
That's certainly part
of his trademark, so.
There's a grit there (clears throat)
♫ Holla holla hng--
You know, I'm gonna leave it at that.
(clears throat)
- That's the music.
Time for Ja Rule trivia.
- [Keith] So what is Ja
Rule's government name?
- Oh, his legal birth name.
- [Keith] Government name, yeah.
- Is it Antoine?
- [Keith] Ja Rule's actual
name is Jeffrey Atkins.
- [Kevin] All right, here'
question number two, Andrew.
Which movie did Ja Rule
appear in with famous actor
Orlando Jones, who was best known
for the 7UP Yours campaign?
- Is it Fast and Furious,
one of the Fast and Furious movies?
- [Kevin] Not even close.
It was Biker Boyz.
Did you see Biker Boyz?
- No.
(slow mo) No.
- All right, Andrew, you're 0 for two.
That's all cool, because
if you nail this one,
you get two whole points.
Last question.
How many Grammy award
nominations has Ja Rule received?
And you gotta remember,
the Grammy awards recognize
excellence in music.
(tense music)
- I believe he's gotten at least two.
- Technically, yeah.
At least two, that was right.
I win.
(slow mo) I win.
I get juice!
I'mma keep it.
- [Keith] That's it,
DJ, can you play us out?
- Holy cow. All right.
♫ Murda
♫ Holla holla
♫ Girl put it on me
- [Kevin] This is the greatest party ever.
(bassy hip hop)
- Man, I just wanted to take some time
to congratulate my dude Ja Rule, man.
He getting released man.
Welcome home, baby.
- My name is Richard Garcia,
I'm a guy who looks a lot like 2Pac.
I wanna give a shout out to Ja Rule,
when you come home for
your touchdown baby,
you know what time it is.
- Be well, enjoy yourself,
get well, stay well,
and most of all, keep on Ja Rule'n!
(sleazy beat)